hi everybody
hey how's it going remember that thing I
did before for about a hundred tries and
did it wrong and was dying a lot it's
not succeeding in any way at all
well that was just a trick I was playing
on you guys to make you think I was dumb
how much time and energy that I waste on
that one track you guys have obviously
pointed it out to me and somewhere in
the back of my mind I thought for some
reason the second block killed me I
don't know why but I did
so obviously the solution is very simple
and you land on this knee up the only
the third one killed and mama got trying
to do something that was impossible from
the beginning I don't know I don't care
let's just go have happy fun this over
here in a method in a magical adventure
that is the next level where are we
going forward and not dying and jumping
on these things that we're supposed to
jump on and my whole existence is Allah
this is all I dunno I just wallow in
despair and agony until until someone
takes mercy on my soul I bet those are
spikes yup they're spikes
how did I know was it the different
color of the obvious placement from
these that you're supposed to jump
across and they're both I bet they're
they're all spikes all the orange ones
are spikes put your tie over it over it
over oh now go to get it does even real
viel itself until I was dead oh
there's more than one it's a spike why
did I land back on this
okay jump on this jump over this and
completely over and then jump jump-jump
you stupid a hole just use your jump
button and jump on over it I'm tired of
it not your back
I'm not even dying for the map I'm dying
from the mic controls the stupidity of
my own demise the stupidity the stupid
ability of my own personage but there
something else in the way no that's it
I got what well what about it
oh okay look so much to see what where
am I going
am I going to oh yeah trust that eternal
happiness you saved us how's that Mouse
always been in there I apologize
i won it's a trick see trick it's a
trick see trick I'm gonna get all the
coins up but get them well not that one
trick Didrik you can't get the middle
one no matter how hard I try I can't get
that one either
bonk bounty bounty bounty ah I saw a cop
it just didn't react fast enough
mr. wait hi hello hello goodbye with
them what hi I was supposed to jump
there you stupid douche the war oh come
on chop chop I dunno Utah Gila what then
kill me before why did that kill me now
just yeah boy yeah boy yeah I was
bugging out Oh doing pretty good
do pretty good until this whole game
stupid I'm gonna get it didn't close I'm
getting closer why why sometimes
why can't you be consistent game what
why now why that doesn't make sense
sometimes maybe oh come on I don't like
to play this game Trixie Trixie Trixie
Trixie Steve sometimes sometimes it does
sometimes it does sometimes it does not
but other times it just decides to be a
whole heck is that bull honky
okay go on Drive oh yeah okay I got a
strategy that I am going to pursue up
okay Kimmy I'm do pro for you let me go
look at me look at me go okay in there
back oh ho ho oh ho oh oh he's like a
fine wine no no what did I beat the game
yeah I did
f you f all of you what what what what I
still live down here what your game
doesn't even work at the end what is
this
kind of anything is I'm just gonna keep
walking here to see what else Oh just
endless clouds of torment
constantly badgering me as I I get so
angry yeah I'm gonna get that fill that
bag of poop roll down that hill go right
and octobots and then we're all gonna
punch him in the dick just whoa Ryan I
mean got easier when I knew what I was
doing and not going the wrong way so
eventually I don't know I'm tired even
the music is okay the music start back
up again but I'm okay you got another
reigns game that you want me to play
write in the comments below if you get
some sort of sick enjoyment out of my
misery you can I don't care I don't care
anymore do what you want do what you
want yeah
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos it
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video